get pest control first then do your
landscaping
[Music]
good morning guys just got back from the
store
and i picked up a few goodies ran some
errands earlier this morning
been a big fan of the spin drift
drifting although i did get a lacroix
i do love my lacroix but
spin drift it's on another level with
some of that real
juice did you know that grapefruit and
the pamplemoose flavor that
lacroix always uses is in fact the same
thing
my mind was blown when i found out
pamphlet moves or is it pamplemousse or
pampa musee musi
anyways uh today is one of those days
where we're gonna be
chilling at the house i'm just gonna
make some food and
spend some family time but before i
forget
this video is brought to you by fetch
rewards
now we're really excited to be teaming
up with fetch rewards
it's basically an app that helps you
save money when you shop or you dine out
and the secret to saving that money
is one of these it's super super easy to
use
all you have to do is download the app
sign up and then scan your receipt make
sure you're on the discover
tab and you'll see an icon that has the
picture of the camera
and all you gotta do is line up your
your receipt bam take a picture of that
now grocery store receipts
are like insanely long i don't know why
they have to be that long but they just
are so what you're gonna do plus sign
and
you scoop down to where you last left
off
and and at the top of that screen you
see it says produce
so we're just gonna match it up take a
picture of that
and you take that too and then
you hit submit and you let the magic
happen here
you see it is uploading bam i just got
500 points
oh that's sweet thank you albertsons now
the cool part
about this too is that if you go back to
the discover tab
there is a another icon next to the uh
the camera icon with an
e if you click on that it'll take you to
your electronic receipts so if you do a
lot of shopping on amazon
which we do too you can definitely
connect your amazon account to fetch
rewards and you can start saving money
through online purchases as well since
here i'm not connected so
i gotta do that asap you know what i
haven't looked over at the rewards tab
yet let's see what kind of rewards they
got and knowing me i love food let's see
what kind of restaurants we got
applebee's book of the peppa buffalo
wild wings
california pizza kitchen what else they
got pets i just did some shopping for my
cats
oh pepco oh my good i just finished
shopping for my cats today
anyways if you want to save some money
download the app now and use our code
tiffcase you get 3000 points when you
scan your first receipt
it's fun it's easy you can start saving
money now today
is a special day for our cats because
today
we are switching out their potty
situation like tiff has said in previous
vlogs
our cats have been notorious for
defecating on furniture and on the floor
with that said actually
pooping on the floor would be much more
pleasant than needing to clean up
our furniture that has poop stains and
poop smells on them so that's been kind
of like the fiasco
with our pets that we've been dealing
with i don't know if you guys can relate
to that
we've been trying to figure that out
we've talked about this multiple times
in our vlogs
a lot of you guys have actually
suggested a lot of great advice maybe
they don't like the kitty litter that
they're using maybe the placement of the
kitty litter is in a place they don't
like
using uh maybe it's too dark maybe it's
too bright maybe it's too
in the open maybe it's too closed off
and we've tried moving the kitty litters
around
in our new place originally we had the
key litters
in the bathroom it was in this room
right here in that corner
but then we're thinking maybe because
it's in the bathroom and it's
dark in here zoe is really the main
culprit here so
you have caused us to move your kitty
litter around so many times
oh they're they're fascinated by the
ants that we got right now
we're having an ant problem too in a
house just because i think
it's hot outside and ants are thriving
in this heat and they're exploring our
house for
for food options and they're not finding
any because when there is a food
option here when there's like a food
that they're just attacking there's like
this long line of ants they're just like
crowding the food source carrying little
bits back to the queen
so these ants though they're not on that
kind of mission
these ants are kind of wandering around
trying to find
something they can't find anything and i
think her cats are like killing them
because then i see like
dead ants every like here and there
they're just like dead ones
i think you guys are like licking them
and biting them and possibly eating them
so yeah our kitty litter needs to be
there
we recently moved the kitty litters to
this corner
and i think they've been liking it and
we've also switched out the kitty litter
too now we're using this corn based
kitty litter that clumps before we're
using that breeze system
where it's like the whole pellets and
like there's a pad underneath and
that system although very easy to use
and um
very easy to maintain it doesn't really
hide
and mask the smell of the urine so give
and take you know
like it does make the job easier but it
also doesn't really
hide the smell which is kind of like the
biggest problem with cats in their urine
like it's just
the ammonia smells terrible but yeah so
now we've opted for these uh
we're simplifying and we're going with
sifting style
kitty litters we're just playing with
our options and uh
see what our cats like and just this
morning
i had to clean you can still see where i
wiped this area is where
i found a piece of poop and i found like
10
pieces of poop here for some reason
though really likes pooping on this
green couch that guy right there we've
also kind of come to the conclusion that
maybe they don't like the pellets the
before it was like clay pellets and it
was probably
hard on their paws and they're indoor
cats so they're not like getting
calluses and they're not
going outside and hardening their paws
so
it's very soft they have like these baby
skin on their paws maybe the softer
texture of like corn based kitty litter
might be uh more inviting for them to
use
this is a nice soft texture hopefully
they'll like it more
i like it more already so now we're
going to try and test out a new area
we're probably gonna replace that
disposable one with one of these guys
and i'm gonna put another one of these
guys instead of going upstairs with it
because we have one upstairs but
and doesn't get a whole lot of action uh
it's just occasional
uh pee here and there no poop ever
really so
downstairs is where they prefer
defecating to stop them from
going over there we're gonna put one
there
and maybe one here just because this
seems like a nice little area
out of the way of the rest of the living
room so
hopefully you like it
done video all right let's see how these
two
kitty litters handle our cats and how
our cats like these two kitty litters
placement and texture wise now that
that's done let's make some lunch
my favorite part of the day
got some rice left over from yesterday
bam i've been chiseling away at this
platter of pork chops that i got
probably make some of those i already
made two of them probably make it for
the rest
make the rest of it today got some
leftover beans from mexican spot that we
like
uh some some salsa so i'll probably
dress the pork chops up with some of
this
serve it with some of that some rice
maybe throw in
an egg for good measure
all right isaac what are we doing here
so i'm planning to make
my own fried rice uh-huh your own fried
rice
so i'm gonna uh chop up these pork chops
yeah break the yolk
put it onto the rice and add the
shredded
pork chops that sounds good that's what
i like to do well i don't necessarily
pre-mix mine but as i'm eating i'm like
mixing all my stuff up and i love how
everything tastes together when it's
like all mushed together in your mouth
yeah and i offer you a rojo
or verde salsa
rojo yes that's good is it
there's a
even the colors have genders so like
it's like salsa
ends with the a so that's why roja which
comes after satsang has to end with the
a's how i understand it but
i didn't formally learn spanish like
textbook wise so i really
don't know but that's what i heard from
other people that have
um learn spanish as a second language
kind of thing
they say that that's a rule but i
remember being in mexico and like
getting the gender confused of an item
and then a family member told me the
same rule so
that's how that's how it's supposed to
be so salsa
learning chinese as a kid too like my
chinese is very like
broken it's like at the level of a
kindergarten kid yeah
it's like i'm talking like baby talk
it's like do you want some
salsa that is red instead of like red
salsa it's like it's just like it takes
a long time to get the point across
the problem with uh growing up bilingual
and in the
melting pot of a country oh you know
you're not using all the rojo
huh a little bit here and there oh it's
like just drenched okay i'll use steve
oh yeah what does steve do like the
entire
plate will just be red trusty is the
kind of guy that goes
i don't know what it tastes like but i
think i already know it needs more salt
and more pepper
all right i'm gonna go for the a better
day you are gender neutral verde
you don't have a dough or a die it's a
day
there we go that's how you do leftovers
that
is a work of art ah there's ants
everywhere all right these ants look
like they found
something they're on a mission and
they're on a mission to get some cat
food that's in here
i guess they didn't really get to it yet
but
uh they're on their way to finding
finding it i just called
pest control and we have a date
uh coming up and they're gonna spray the
houses this will be the first time this
house has received pest control
treatment and the way they explain to me
is
you create a barrier around your house
so that any ants or any bugs that
are coming around will be deterred by
the spray and so as it is it's not
because we have food laying around or
anything like that
mainly because we don't have that
barrier set up and so they're just kind
of roaming around oh yes but the lady on
the phone did say
that if we're gonna do landscaping
because i asked her like we're doing
landscaping soon
so would would that affect the
effectiveness
of the spray she was saying if anything
you might want to do the pest control
first because once you you start
landscaping you till up the ground the
the soil and stuff a lot of the critters
are going to come out and what they're
going to do is
try to find refuge so you actually might
see even more
ants and bugs and stuff in and around
the house so if you guys are homeowners
too
get pest control first then do your
landscaping man being a homeowner you
get to learn a lot of different things
that you never thought was even a thing
to even know all right so i've been
packing a lot of projects
around the house getting the landscaping
and like the planning of that and like
budgeting at that was a
pretty big one well that's really about
it everything else has just been like
you know getting cooking videos done
your vlogs done working on like you know
junebe and shrimp daddy
content another project this project
i've kind of uh i've kind of dropped the
ball on this one
and it's a it's a big project and you
can really see how big this project is
since
tiff and isaac just left and uh
and there's no car in here
all that all
that must go this is all our old
furniture
from the couches that we used to have in
the living room to
a couch that was in isaac's room to our
old
dresser to our old desks dvd shelves
our dining table that we've disassembled
it's like in parts
over there tiff's aunt has called dibs
on these tables right here
and i believe the big mood podcast wants
this circle shelf
but everything else must go the bed back
there and i'm just looking at this like
i don't want to deal with it
gotta post it on offer up or craigslist
and uh sell this crap yeah another thing
too that's kind of been
stopping me from wanting to do it is
pricing this stuff because i i know
people on craigslist and offer up are
looking for a deal they're looking for
like you know give me give me a couch
for 100 bucks you know 200 bucks max
but i've talked to tiff and we know
these couches that we got
are like about a thousand each uh
quality build we
we've loved these couches for the time
that we've had them for we just decided
to go in a different you know
style for the new house but we know the
value of these couches and uh
it hurts to think that we're gonna sell
a thousand dollar couch for a hundred
bucks
part of me is like well maybe we should
sell it in order
of how it's laid out in this garage
because if we sell
say like the bed over there it's like i
don't want to i don't want to deal with
moving everything
so i just might as well sell the stuff
that's in front and just kind of go in
order so we don't actually have to
shuffle anything around
and i had a few offers and they're
trying to lowball me and whatnot
and i'm like i don't know i'm kind of
firm on my price right now and uh
probably gonna have to just drop the
price in order to get rid of it because
now we're just kind of like sitting here
like
i want to move my car in here and maybe
i'm just getting desperate to get rid of
it now i don't know
you win offer up you win what are you
doing
playing with the cats you kind of got
over it now
playing for a minute you came too late
[Music]
[Applause]
and i was telling i was telling everyone
about like how we switched the
kitty litters and the pellets might be
too hard on their paws
the softest little paws ever
yeah a prince and a princess over here
ants everywhere i know i also said i
said that we scheduled and
he looks over it he's like i'm tired
eight-year-old
old man man you are older
[Music]
he's slowly melting to the ground
he's like i give up fine you want to
cuddle
we can cuddle you dropped his butt cats
love you the most
let me manhandle them yeah what's funny
about
our cats is that our cats have different
relationships with each one of us
as humans and they definitely
like tiff the most in terms of uh
letting her hug and cuddle
and like just do whatever so you get to
have that access to which me and isaac
don't and they like always run away from
us and stuff and so
i always feel so left out and i'm the
one that does
kitty litters all the time i'm the one
that takes care of the food so
maybe that's why they're like she's the
one that feeds us true you do feed them
and you do
and in terms of water like i always
forget to do the water too so
make sure that they stay alive true the
handle will goes in
your head all goes down dang you gotta
treat me like that
yeah you pick up my breath i know
you should be more grateful for the
people that pick up your crap
all right guys it is dinner time and i'm
about to make some food
and what i'm making tonight is minchi
and it is a macanese chinese dish so
macanese as in like macau china
and what it is it's like minced meat
with some onions and some soy sauce
and it's pretty good really simple uh
recipe very much at home
food and what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
take that pork
chop grease that i have here from
earlier
i'm gonna heat it up and there's some
onions in there and i'm gonna utilize
all this flavor that's here already
so tonight we are feasting on some
minchi
and it is a dish from cow china
and it's traditionally made with beef
and pork but we only
we had turkey and i wanted to use up the
ground turkey
but it's cooked in some soy sauce and
you serve it with some rice and an
egg on top and traditionally it's served
with fried potatoes but instead of fried
potatoes
french fries we got french fries it's
kind of like lomo saltado a bit too
you know what i mean yeah yeah anyways
big shout outs to fetch rewards be sure
to use the code tiffcase when you scan
your first receipt to get 3 000 points
and
save some money
[Music]
you